hello everyone and welcome to round four
of the usgs championship 2021 this is
the most awaited clash in the one that
you guys requested the most uh it's
wesley so versus fabiano caruana and
even though this game uh probably did
not live up to its full potential uh you
guys are here to help rectify that so
without further ado let's check it out
as wesley has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 uh we have knight to f6 by
fabi c for e6 knight to c3 and bishop to
b4 fabi goes for the nimzo indian
defense
and wesley replies with the classical
variation and that is queen to c2
putting more pressure on the
e4 square so you have support for
advancing your e4 pawn if needed but
also if black captures on c3 as one
usually does in the names of indian you
don't have to capture with the b-pawn
you could also capture with the queen so
here fabi castles and wesley goes a3
challenging the bishop on b4 bishop
captures in c3 queen captures now and d6
and here knight to f3 just nicely
continuing development and usually uh
the
mostly played moves here are b6
preparing to find ghetto or light square
bishop or knight beat to d7 but fabi
plays rook to e8 which is a very rare
move and obviously he prepared something
very special for wesley wesley continues
with b4 grabs more space on the queen
side uh this does
like we said expand on the queen side
but it keeps the king in the center for
a little bit longer which could be
dangerous against the names of indian
but here you can see it's a very timid
setup it's not another very aggressive
one and now uh e5 here right away as you
made uh sure the rook is on e8 and also
knight b to d7 are known moves but the
move fobby plays is a new move so
already as of move eight we have a
completely new game uh fabi plays a5
challenges the b4 pawn and now you have
to be careful if pawn captures queen
captures you cannot capture with your a
pawn otherwise the real kings you would
mess up your pawn structure so of course
uh here wesley plays bishop to b2 now
you will be able to capture back with
your pawn a captus on b for a captures
on b4 and now rook captures on a1 with
check we have bishop captures by wesley
and now b5 so this is the uh preparation
probably fabi had for this game of
course it goes way way beyond that but
uh
it's very uh uh very wild uh it gives up
a pawn already on move 11 and you want
to mess up white spawn structure so it
definitely makes sense later on you can
blockade the doubled pawns with knight
knight to d7 and knight to v6 uh and
then continue from there so wesley says
all right uh not accepting this pawn for
example c5 bishop b7 could be a little
bit dangerous uh i'm not really doing
anything here so i'm going to accept the
pawn and see what you had in mind so
here c captures on b5 by wesley and now
knight b to d7 uh we have e3 wesley
wants to develop his light square bishop
castle to safety and now knight to b6
now both of the knights are nicely
guarding that d5 square and the knight
is an excellent blockading piece for
example when you want to blockade
doubled pawns because there is no a pawn
or c pawn to dislodge this knight
we have bishop to d3 a very aggressive
approach also bishop to e2
might be possible but fabi just plays
bishop to b7 and he says uh since your
bishop is not an e2 i will very gladly
capture this knight on f3 wesley says be
my guest i'm not worried about that he
castles
and fabi captures it this definitely
makes sense it's a it's an incredibly
strong piece but it's uh
uh it's very difficult to not to ruin
blacks uh white's king side by capturing
an f3 so fab he captures that g captures
and now knight f to d5
attacking the queen putting more
pressure here
on the central pawn and also maybe
preparing ideas like f5 e5 uh the queen
might be coming into the game also if e5
is played maybe rook here rook to h6 so
those are fabi's ideas we queen to b3
sidestepping this and now a queen to h4
the main idea here is do you play f5 or
not uh because of course you want to
block this light square bishop wesley
has the bishop pair and it's an
incredibly strong bishop pair but for
the moment it's not doing all that much
after a move like f5 is played but it's
a very committal move uh the queen now
has control of this wonderful diagonal
if the knight ever moves you can even
capture here since the pawn is pinned so
it's a very tricky on how you would
actually get your pieces into the attack
if you go some like queen here bring the
rook here that's that's a lot of moves
so far before the moment uh uh waits
with the df5 push he plays queen to h4
and now comes king the g2 by wesley this
is a move you want to remember for when
your king side is busted uh you want to
play king to g1 king to g2 bring the
rook behind the king and then uh sort of
uh artificially castle backwards uh to
save safety sort of king to f1 king to
e2 and then use the the semi-open g file
for your attack uh and now once again
fabi uh is asking himself uh whether f5
is the right approach here do i wait
with uh f5 uh and he decides to push e5
instead now what do you what do you plan
on doing here uh well it's a very
complicated position and we are almost
at the point where the position comes it
becomes incredibly interesting here d
captures an e5 is played why not of
course you want to open up this diagonal
for your dark square bishop uh and here
fabi played rook to e6 and this is a
very very brave by fabi sacrificing
another pawn wesley is now up two pawns
and now he wants to bring his rook into
the attack
but the position is now actually lost
for fabi but it's such a complicated
idea uh that um
well not not everyone would find it as
you'll see in the game but you guys are
comfortable in your own homes i imagine
it's a very nice sunday
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to figure out how can wesley make
incredible progress here while i give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations uh on uh figuring
out its adolf anderson's move and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's rook to d1 that's that's the
move you had to find this move was not
played in the game and this is the move
we are going to discuss just to give you
an example of course the idea is we want
to free up our
f1 square so the king can go to safety
because the king isn't very safe on the
king side anymore
and also if you try something like rook
the g one which seems even better as you
know this position might open up uh not
really because after d captures on e5
you're not really opening up this
diagonal any longer and if king to f1
running to safety we can even play queen
captures on h2 and now after a move like
f4 we want to open up this diagonal
queen to h3 check for example king to e1
and now even knight captures an e3 so
there are ideas like this in the
position and the white would be
i wouldn't be very happy here especially
if you capture for example queen
captures here attacks the rook you have
to guard the rook captures on f4 king e1
queen e3 check and again if you guard
the rook rook f6 check and that's it
you're just getting checkmated here king
wherever rook to h6 will be checkmate so
uh it's important that you move the rook
here and now the idea is that our king
will be very safe on e2 and we actually
want to attack in the center and on the
queen side now once the bishop moves
there will be a nice attack on this
knight here and another thing uh to
figure out rook to d1 you have to find
the next move for example d captures on
e5 what do you play now bishop to e4 and
bishop to e4
is the star move of this variation
because after bishop to e4 black is
completely helpless there is no attack
here there is nothing you can do
your knight is hanging here obviously we
have to take care of that so let's say
knight f6 we go after the bishop not a
problem rook to d8 to check and now what
do you do if you block with the rook
then it's too easy for white queen to d3
and that's pressure you're not getting
rid of so knight to d8 a little bit uh
better for black but still we're just
going to play queen to d3 and there is
no attack here there is no
there's nothing here for black king f1
to e2 uh solves all of your problems and
there's nothing you can do for example
king f8 we want to add a defender here
bishop to c6 is coming and now again
what you play here
it's uh very hard to even find the move
because there is no attack here for
black and the black is uh banking in
everything here on the attack happening
on the king's side so here you would
probably have to offer a queen trade and
let's say after captures captures now we
have this f4 move
that's that's the good stuff uh so of
course if you capture the bishop is
coming to c5 denta to d4 then to c5 and
then it's just game over
for example if you capture on f4 we're
going to play bishop to d4 now you have
to make some room for the king bishop to
c5 check but it still doesn't help if
you move the king we just pick up the
knight and if you play knight to d6 then
the point is now the double b pawn
becomes the star of the show bishop
captures on d6 and you have to capture
with the pawn otherwise just uh we just
win a piece so we're gonna have to
capture with the pawn now b6 and now the
pass pawn wins the game easily so that's
what you would face here after this f4
move so you can't really capture you
might as well play something like f6 but
now uh we're just going to play bishop
to c3 and now when evaluating this
position you can see that the white king
is very active the black king has no
activity it doesn't really have any
moves you can't really push any pawns
capture anything and it's just really
really bad so what you're asking
yourself uh here is uh is the bishop
pair uh that the wesley has better than
the night pair that fabi has and
obviously it's much much better so this
would be easily winning for fabi however
after five
for wesley however after fabi's rook to
e6 move it's uh really a lot to consider
because first you have to
realize that the king will be safe here
and you have to uh realize that king f1
to e2 followed by bishop to e4 and then
your position is simply uh uh uh
untouchable this bishop to e4 is such a
star move uh because you can you can
even play bishop to e4 or you can play
f4 and then the bishop covers the uh the
the g2 and the h1 square so you can
really uh just play
any anything here so just rook the rook
to d1 and just everything works it's
just amazing the captures it's uh
such a such a fine fine position that um
it's it's very hard to you know
there's nothing you can do here like
everything everything works in this
position however after rook to e6 uh
fabi just played e cap e captures on d6
is what wesley played uh and now uh it's
much easier for fabi to you know
consolidate in this position this also
this move also has merit it really opens
up the bishop pair but there is simply
no time to activate it because now of
course i don't even have to tell you
what fabi's move was if i played queen
to g5 check and now our rook on f1 that
in the variation that we discussed was
on d1 that makes it very problematic for
the white king to escape so king the h1
was played now queen to h5 by fabi going
after the f3 pawn and there's no way for
wesley to
gain the advantage that could have been
gained
in the previous line so he simply played
queen to b2 he threatened checkmate uh
but now queen captures on f3 with king
g1 and here after queen to g for chuck
king h1 queen after reaching king to g1
queen g for chuck king to h1 and queen
f3 check
we have a draw by threefold repetition
even though it's below 30 moves uh of
course three-fold repetition seals the
game
so really um a nice gambit by fabi going
for that really really crazy line with
the pawn sacrifice and then with the
other pawn sacrifice but had wesley
found that rook to d1 move it would be
it would be of course completely winning
in in the hands of a player like wesley
so
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it so after after this draw
uh
neither of them can uh you know clinch
that first place uh in solely just yet
but uh someone else has done it and
we're gonna discuss that in in the next
video uh but yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it uh i would like to
wish a very happy birthday to natalia i
hope you have a great day filled with
chess and joy uh and i also i would like
to thank olga the dinosaur david kimura
ravindra yoga and bernal tapa for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
us chess championship checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world so thank
y'all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your sunday